it is the new year that means you want
to make sure your finances are in order
in today's 8 on your side we connected
with the ceo of brokers international
mark williams about the key things you
need to go over to set you up for a
successful 2022
first things first make sure you have
socked away as much as possible into
your retirement accounts you're allowed
to contribute a certain amount of your
money which is uh comes out pre-tax into
a 401k or possibly an ria or after tax
with roth ir ria
and you really want to make sure that
you're contributing because you get that
tax benefit every year speaking of
savings if you created a savings goal
throughout the year see if you're on
track make sure you have that emergency
fund in place just in case and because
credit history is so crucial make sure
yours is reflected accurately check your
credit reports
you should do it on a regular basis
anyway but if you put a little tickler
in your calendar that says ooh check it
at the end of the year it's one of those
things that you want to keep up with
most importantly for discrepancies you
can sign up with all three of the major
credit bureaus for a free credit report
annually or go through your banking
location even credit card companies
offer a service and here's one tip that
is important to check if you have had a
change in your marriage status or
personal circumstances double check your
beneficiaries on your life insurance
policies on your health insurance
policies um divorce death marriage you
want to make sure that god forbid
something happen the right people get
the right money
always great also double check your
withholding status to determine if
you're pulling enough out and adjust it
if you aren't